The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osu.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so we're going
to do a basic three-point
lighting setup.
This is one of the kits I use.
This is a compact, one-case
lighting kit as I call it.
It's got a few-- we're going
to go over what's in it here.
Here's one very important
item in the kit.
It has everything
to do with lighting.
Transparent microbubble powder.
Sometimes, your subject
will be a little too shiny
under the lights, and
this transparent base
will get rid of the
shine without changing
the color of their complexion.
And if you use the
transparent powder,
always use a brand
new makeup pad
or wedge because you don't
want to cause problems.
But that's an essential
item in the kit.
This is a grid, which
we'll see in a moment.
We'll pull that out.
A couple of extension cords.
Very useful items to have.
This is the Lowel Rifa.
What's really nice
about the Rifa
is that it's very
compact, soft light that
folds up like an umbrella.
And very easy to pop open.
And it opens up like that.
And we will revisit
this in a moment.
Extension cords.
And if my extension cord doesn't
have multiple taps on the end,
I always attach a cube
tap because you never
know when you're going to need
to plug in something else.
This is the Lowel Tota.
Basic open face light.
Comes with a safety screen.
And you should always
use it with the screen.
Quartz halogen lamps.
When they shatter, you
don't want hot glass
anywhere near living things.
So if you use the
Lowel Tota Light,
you definitely want to
make sure that the safety
screen is always on it.
The new generation V light
encapsulates the lamp inside
of a glass case for safety.
But that's the older style.
Here's a Fresnel instrument.
There is your
scalloped glass lens.
And all Fresnel instruments
have a flood to the right spot,
to the left flood.
The cleanest, most even light
source comes in flood mode.
And we'll see how that
floods and spots in a moment.
Barn doors are usually included.
And we'll put these
on the Fresnel.
And the barn doors are used
for controlling the spill.
And they get their
name because they
seem to look like barn doors.
Of course, I've
never seen a barn
that's shaped round like that.
But usually travel with
a second extension cord.
This one's green because
I bought it at 75% off
in an after Christmas sale.
That's the best time
to buy extension cords.
For some reason the
green ones become
much cheaper than the
other colored ones the day
after Christmas.
Manfrotto makes a
variety of light stands.
These are nice, lightweight
aluminum stands,
which are very handy for
when you're traveling.
And we will set
those up in a moment.
When you set up the
stands, you should always
make sure that the bottoms
are as wide out as they
go for maximum stability.
And here's the umbrella that
goes with the Tota-light, which
we will be using today as well.
So this attaches.
The Tota-light has an accessory,
has an accessory connection
thing--
that's a technical term, thing--
that it attaches to
the light, and that
gives us a nice, soft light,
which we'll see in a moment.
Here's the quarter blue
gel I was talking about.
So for example, if I
hold this over the lens
and we set the white
balance, we can actually
increase the warmth
of the world.
So we can fool the
white balance circuit
into thinking that the
world is more blue.
And then we pull
it, pull it away.
So this eighth blue gel is
very handy dandy thing to have.
Also in the kit we
have the Siemens stars
for focusing, for
precise focusing.
These are really
easy to focus on.
And this is also a gray card,
and on the opposite side
a white card for balancing.
You never know
when you might have
trouble finding an 8 and 1/2
by 11 piece of white paper.
So I always keep the white
card in the kit as well.
We talked about gloves.
These will keep you
from burning your hands.
And very important, always
have a set of spare lamps.
Lamps have a
tendency to burn out
in the most inopportune moment.
So I always keep spare lamps
in a nice little cushioned box.
Sometimes when you're shooting
outdoors, all you need
is a reflector to
fill in the shadows.
This wonderful device
called the Flexfill,
which opens up like this.
They come in
different varieties.
I like the matte silver
on one side and the matte
white on the other.
So if we need to
fill in the shadows
with a very, very kind of spunky
light or a very, very subtle
light, we have those two sides.
You store them away by
giving them a little twist
and throwing them
back into the case.
You can get accessories
that will hold the Flexfill
and you can attach
it to a light stand.
I have one of those
in my larger kit.
But that usually doesn't
travel in the smaller kit.
And sometimes I want to color,
I want to color the light.
I keep a little file here with
a variety of colored gels--
blues for cooling things
off, orange and pink gels
for warming things up.
I actually put these in
the order of the rainbow.
And of course, and I
also have a bunch of--
I keep the orange and the blues
for warming up and cooling
lights in their own set,
along with some diffusion.
So if I want to diffuse
the light, for example,
this is standard 216
or full diffusion.
You put this over light
and it'll really soften it.
So we're going to look
at some diffusion today.
And this is actually
a half blue gel
that is actually specifically
cut for use with the Rifa-lite.
The blue gel is used to
bring the warm tungsten light
of the Rifa closer to daylight.
I use the half blue
instead of the full blue
because the full blue cuts the
light way too much, kind of
like, is it 2 or
2 and 1/2 stops?
The full blue cuts the
light a little too much.
The half blue still gives
me some light intensity
to work with.
So often I will
split the difference
in the white balance.
So I keep one of
these specifically cut
and sized for the
Rifa-lite so it
can be attached really quickly.
Now it's very
important-- the Rifa-lite
has a bare, incandescent lamp.
It's very important that
you don't touch the lamp.
You don't want to get
finger oils on it.
They can cause the
fingerprint area
to be at a different temperature
than the rest of the lamp
and the glass could crack.
So you want to be very careful.
Never operate the Rifa-lite
without the diffusion cover.
So here's the low Rifa.
And there is an optional
accessory, the offset arm,
which is really important.
If you're mounting this on a
relatively lightweight stand,
it's going to tip
over really easily.
But with the offset
arm, the weight
is balanced evenly
on a light stand.
So this offset arm is a
pretty important accessory.
Never use the light
without the diffusion cover
because this not only is
providing the diffused light,
but it's also covering up
the quartz halogen lamp,
because you never want to
have a bare lamp in front
of your talent.
And this kind of
attaches with Velcro.
Here we go.
So there is our soft light.
It comes with a short cord.
And so we need the, comes with
its own little extension cord
with a standard IEC connector.
And there is our soft key.
And Zack, could you plug
that into the power strip?
All right.
So now we have a
lovely soft light,
which we'll use as our key.
So Chris, are you ready
for your interview?
CHRIS BOEBEL: I am.
DAVID TAMES: All right.
So we're going to
interview Chris today.
And here is Zack, is going
to be operating camera.
And we're going to
start with our Rifa-lite
as our key light on Chris.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Glasses
on or off, David?
DAVID TAMES: Glasses on.
CHRIS BOEBEL: OK.
DAVID TAMES: It gives us
more fun to work with.
Right?
So now, right now we're
using the Rifa as our key,
and we have a lot of overhead
lights in this classroom.
I'm going to turn off the
ambient light for now.
So this is a single key light,
no fill, no background light,
no backlight.
Pretty dramatic.
What we would call a
very high lighting ratio,
probably something
worthy of film noir.
It may or may not be
appropriate for our piece,
but that is our starting point.
We typically set our key
light, our primary light source
and determine what
we want it to do.
Notice how we get a
very different quality
if I raise the key
light a little bit.
And if I move it off to the
side versus moving it more
towards the front, this is
a little more glamorous.
Now there's no dramatic shadow.
It's almost like an overhead
towards the front key light.
So notice how as we
bring it to the side
and bring it down a little bit,
we have a much more dramatic
arrangement.
So now what we want
to do is we want
to fill the shadows that are
being created by the key light
and maybe bring a back
light or a background light
into the picture.
For the fill light, I think
we'll use our Tota-light
with an umbrella.
What's handy about
all these lowlights
is they use the same
connector, same cable style.
It's nice that all the
lowlights have pretty much
the same connector
and wiring system.
They're interchangeable.
And they wrap easily into a case
and can be stored very portably
because the cords separate out.
So we're going to use
this Tota as our fill.
And notice what's going on
here, that now our situation is
a little less dramatic.
And as I bring
the fill light in,
I'm reducing the contrast ratio.
So when we talk
about contrast ratio,
we're talking about the
ratio between the fill light
and key, the fill and key
together, and just the fill.
So notice that in this
case, the fill and the key
are very similar in intensity.
They're kind of, the
ratio is almost 1 to 1,
might be closer to 1 to 2.
So as I bring my key--
sorry, as I bring
my fill light back,
I'm increasing
the lighting ratio
and providing a more
dramatic experience.
I'm providing a more
dramatic lighting
situation for the subject.
Now since this is, we might
split the difference there
and go with something like that.
How does that look, Zack?
GUEST SPEAKER: It looks good.
DAVID TAMES: All right.
So now, we have a choice.
We we can give Chris a backlight
for a more dramatic theatrical
look, or we can simply
use our third light source
as a background light.
But I think what we'll do now is
let's see what a backlight does
for Chris.
So we're going to use
this 300 Watt Fresnel
as a backlight on Chris.
We're going to set
it up over here.
Sometimes I do it
opposite the key.
A lot of times, it
depends on my mood,
what seems to make sense for the
particular scene in question.
Notice that we're getting
light directly into the camera.
You can see-- you're
getting flares, Jared?
So we're getting flares in
probably both camera lenses.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Both cameras.
DAVID TAMES: Notice how by
adjusting the barn doors,
I can reduce that lens flare.
So what's nice about a
Fresnel instrument is
the barn doors actually work
because the light beams are
so straight, they're
easy to control.
So what we've done here is we've
provided a backlight on Chris
and we've used the barn doors
to reduce the spill directly
into the camera lens to avoid
that flare that you saw.
Now, this is looking kind of
dramatic, wouldn't you say?
Now, we've got these great
little things called scrims,
which we can pop into
our Fresnel instrument
and reduce the intensity.
CHRIS BOEBEL: A scrim is
just a wire screen that
fits in front of the
lamp and cuts out,
literally just cuts down how
much light comes out of it.
DAVID TAMES: So
notice I have brought
down the intensity
of the backlight
without having to move it
and change its position
and quality.
I've just used the scrims
to reduce the intensity.
So that's another--
most Fresnel instruments
have slots for single
or double scrims.
A double scrim basically cuts
the light one stop, cuts it
in half, or you can cut it
less with a single scrim.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The other nice
thing about a scrim, if just--
DAVID TAMES: Those are halves.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So
this also allows
you to cut the bottom
part or the top part.
You can actually adjust where
the scrim goes in the light
and have some control over
which part, up or down,
side left or right is cut more.
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
So there's single and
doubles, and there's halves,
which are physically half.
So sometimes you
want half the beam
to be brighter than
the other half.
Now sometimes I
like my backlights
to be a slightly different
color than my key lights.
So I'm going to put a blue
gel, attaching it to the barn
doors with clothespins,
also known as C-47s.
And notice what's
going on now is
we've cooled off a little bit.
And I might want to
remove those scrims now.
By the way, scrims
can get very hot.
You don't want to pull them
out with your bare hands.
Sometimes people will
take a pair of clothespins
and hook it up
backwards and you end up
with what's called
a scrim puller.
So notice now that my
backlight is a little bluish
and it's a little intense.
We might want to
tweak this further.
But for the sake of this demo--
how are the glasses looking?
Another issue that we deal
with is reflections in glasses.
So there's several
things we can do
about reflections in glasses.
One thing we can do is we can
move the position of our key.
Crossing.
All right.
Sometimes that can help.
We have a tricky situation here
with both the fill and the key.
But notice now
we've reduced, we've
eliminated that
second reflection.
We do have, we still
have a little bit
of reflection in the glasses,
but as Chris talks and moves
his head a little bit,
you want to watch out.
Some people simply say
take your glasses off.
I like to do a little bit of
extra work and ask people,
do you normally
wear glasses or not?
If they take them off
because they'd only wear them
some of the times, fine.
If they usually
wear their glasses,
I'll spend a little extra
time tweaking the lights
and get it to look nice so
that I'm photographing people
the way they normally appear.
Sometimes changing the position
by tilting the legs up or down
a little bit, sometimes a
little bit of adjustment
can help with the
reflection in glasses.
It's a little tricky,
but it can work.
So this is a pretty
simple, straightforward
three-point-- key, fill, back.
We could have added
some accent lights
for details in the background.
We could have added a background
light to light our background.
But we're just going to
keep it simple for the sake
of this demo.
So notice what happens now.
So here's our backlight.
Here's our fill.
Here's our key light.
We'll fill in the shadows
with our fill light,
and we'll provide a little bit
of drama or theatrical essence
with our backlight and give
a little bit of separation
between foreground
and background.
One more thing.
The thing about soft
lights is they spill a lot.
So notice how our
key is spilling
all over the background.
There's one more
accessory that I
carry in the light kit
along with the soft light,
and that's called a grid.
And what this grid
will do is it will
reduce the spill of the light.
And it's available in different
size grids for different angles
of allowing different beat.
It's available in
different size grids,
providing different
amounts of spill reduction.
So now with the grid,
using the grid in our key,
you will notice it does
reduce the intensity
of the key light a bit.
However, notice, and it might
be hard to see from this camera,
but we've dramatically
reduced the amount of spill
on the background.
We've eliminated
the background spill
and the light is
primarily on the subject.
And since the
intensity of our key
came down, because
the grid does reduce
the intensity of
the light a bit,
I might want to pull my fill
light back a little bit.
So now we have a somewhat
dramatic interview setup.
We're still getting a little bit
of reflection with the glasses.
That's something that
we would need to tweak.
One more thing I might do
in a situation like this,
but we're going to
skip it for brevity,
is I might add an additional
light unit in order
to provide some definition
in the background.
One last thing.
By the way, instead
of using a fill light,
I could have used the Flexfill.
So notice how here,
grabbing some of the light
from the key light,
I can actually
use the silver side
of the Flexfill
to fill in the shadows.
Though sometimes in
an interview setup
it might be better
to have a light unit
farther away from the
subject than the Flexfill.
But the Flexfill
is kind of handy
and it doesn't have to
be plugged into the wall.
All right, one last thing I
want to show is a scrim puller.
So Fresnel instruments
usually allow
you to pop in scrims
so that you can
adjust the intensity of the
light once it's in place.
Because the scrims are
metal, they get really hot.
So if you reassemble a
pair of clothespins kind
of with the clips
backwards, you can actually
create what's called
a scrim puller.
And you want to use those
for popping out the scrims
because they can get
really hot and you don't
want to burn your fingers.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So
what we've done here
is a pretty traditional,
straightforward
three-point lighting
setup for an interview,
and I just wanted to
make a couple of points
about what other things
to think about if this
were, in fact, an interview.
So David has set me up here.
I'm the interview subject, he's
the interviewer, presumably.
In a traditional
interview situation,
I would be looking
just off-camera,
either to the left or the right.
And what we have set up here
with the main on this side
is essentially
probably something
that would favor me looking
to the left of the camera.
So David, if you stand where
the interviewer would be--
DAVID TAMES: Hey there.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --and I'm
talking to you here,
you see that I'm just looking
a little bit off-camera.
Maybe I'm looking here.
This is the side that is the
main side of the lighting.
It's more brightly lit.
And then the other
thing would be
thinking about framing in
relation to the lighting.
I don't know what kind
of frame you have there
since I'm not the
director, but you
might want to think about
whether this kind of lighting
and this kind of
frame works well
in both a fairly close shot,
depending on the style you're
going for, and a wider
shot, because you
may want to vary the frame
size during the course
of the interview.
When David asked me the
very emotional question
about my childhood, this is
the 60 Minutes interview.
You'll be much tighter.
DAVID TAMES: You
want to zoom in for
that perfect little teardrop.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Exactly.
Yes, the teardrop quivering
on just the edge of the--
DAVID TAMES: Little
did we know--
CHRIS BOEBEL: --the eye.
DAVID TAMES: --there was a cut
and a makeup person put that
there with an eye dropper.
CHRIS BOEBEL: [LAUGHS]
DAVID TAMES: [LAUGHS]
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yes,
when I was scared
by a video camera
at age four and it
changed the course of my life.
But anyway, so I just
wanted to point that out
that this could be an actual
live interview situation
and there would be things that
we would be thinking about,
both in terms of framing
and position of the subject,
and the lighting impacts that.
DAVID TAMES: Right.
Another thing I'd like
to add to that is I
typically do not do
all of this setup
with the interview
subject standing in.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yes.
DAVID TAMES: So
typically, I work
in a two-person
team and the person
doing the interview will hang
out with the interview subject
and kind of chat with them
and kind of warm things up,
and do that away from
all the technical setup
and I will do the
technical setup
and then only do the very last
minute tweaking and adjustments
with the subject sitting under
the lights, because it could
take 30 minutes to set
everything up really carefully,
sound, lighting, et
cetera, and you don't want
to put people through that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, I mean,
we have a separate class
on interview
techniques and things
to think about when
doing an interview.
But the comfort and relaxed
state of your subject
is obviously really,
really crucial.
And putting them through what
I just went through, you know,
I'm patient because I don't
mind being a guinea pig here,
but putting them through
that is not a good way
to begin a relationship when
you're going to be asking them
questions.
Similarly, another
point I wanted
to make about the lighting
is you want to, obviously,
make things look good
and put the lights
where they need to be in order
to get a good image and a look
that works for you.
But you also want to think about
the comfort of your subject.
So again, having
something glaring directly
in their eyes, a very powerful
light can be a problem.
And raising the
light a little bit
higher so that it's not as--
see, right there, that
makes a huge difference.
DAVID TAMES: Right.
In fact, usually--
and that's actually
another reason why I prefer
the [? sidey ?] light.
It's not just about
being dramatic and kind
of following in the Rembrandt
tradition, but a lot of it
is also driven by not having
the light glare directly
into the subject.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So now if
I'm talking to David back
in the interviewer
position, I can see him,
I'm not looking into the light.
It's just much more
comfortable for me.
There's also another thing that
people often do called comfort
lights, which basically would
be another small light that
actually isn't
lighting me at all,
but is a very low
power light that's
lighting David or
lighting the background
so that I'm not just
staring into this black well
with these bright
lights pointing at me.
I actually can see
who I'm talking to,
I can see the environment
just a little bit.
And we keep them very
low and very low power
so that they don't
actually affect the image,
but it just adds to the
comfort level of the person.
But yeah, David also made an
extremely good and important
point that when you're
working doing an interview,
particularly if it is kind
of a sensitive subject,
having two people is really,
really important not just
to schlep the equipment,
but because one person can
be developing a rapport
with the interview subject
while the other person is
handling all of this stuff.
And it gets really,
really difficult
sometimes if you put
somebody through,
especially someone who's not
really used to doing this,
through this whole experience
of the tweaking and the lighting
setup and glaring lights in
their eyes, and then you say,
Go, ready, start.
And that can be a very
off-putting experience.
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
And one last thing is we've done
this pretty dramatic, almost
theatrical setup for
this particular demo.
But if I was interviewing Chris
about teaching this class,
we would probably
find a nice window,
maybe facing north or south so
we don't get direct sunlight
in the middle of
the interview, we'd
sit by that window and some
soft light, and we'd talk there,
and I'd probably never pull
a lighting instrument out
of the kit.
So start with Mother Nature,
see if the natural light works
for you, and if not, you can
always work artificially.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And remember to
apply the principles that we've
been talking about, both in the
lecture part and in this demo,
to non-lighting
instrument situations.
A little bit of backlight
adds a lot of definition.
Well, there are other
ways to get backlight
than setting up a light.
DAVID TAMES: Maybe we
should do one last setup--
CHRIS BOEBEL: Sure.
DAVID TAMES: --using the natural
lights available in this room.
CHRIS BOEBEL: The camera
currently is not correctly
white balanced.
That's why everything
looks orange.
And we're going to do a
white balance for you.
DAVID TAMES: So
here's a white card.
All right.
So here, let's white
balance the taking camera.
Zack is going to white
balance the Sony a1.
P menu and then white balance.
And then there's the one push.
All right.
So now this is what Chris looks
like with a technically correct
white balance.
So now let's do that again.
Chris, if you could
hold up the white card.
Let's do that again and
hold an eighth blue filter
over the lens.
We're going to fool the
camera into thinking
there's more blue in the world.
Now we're going to do the
one push white balance.
DAVID TAMES: Got it?
And now we pull away
the blue, and Chris
looks a little warmer.
A teeny bit warmer.
Just a tad.
It's like adding a little bit of
basil to your spaghetti sauce.
Slightly more flavorful.
Now this is beautiful
window light.
We're not getting direct
sun shining into the room.
So it's all beautiful,
soft sky light.
And from this camera angle
that Zack is shooting from,
looks reasonably good.
It's a bit dramatic
because remember
that inverse square law.
It's kind of hard
to get away from it.
The light falls
off pretty quickly.
But at this angle, Chris, if
you look at me, from this angle
we're getting a pretty
nice wrap around his face.
Clearly, we have a bright side
and a darker side of the face,
but it looks very natural.
It's kind of hard to beat really
nice, Vermeer-like soft window
light.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
of course, just
as you can change the
light or the position
of the light in the
other setup, here you
could change the
position of the subject.
So you could have me move, and
if you could just pan with me,
move this way.
DAVID TAMES: If I
move Chris back--
CHRIS BOEBEL: And as I
move here, it gets flatter.
I'm lit from the front.
DAVID TAMES: See,
notice how flat that is?
But now, Chris, if
you move right here
and look straight into the
camera and look over here now,
see how dramatic that is with
a dark side and a light side?
So just, now look at me.
Look at how that
dramatically changes.
So in just this small area,
moving the camera a little bit,
moving the subject
a little bit, we
can adjust the light
for what works.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And it
ultimately depends
on determining what
works for your scene.
DAVID TAMES: Exactly.
And if we need fill, we
could bring in the Flexfill
if necessary.
But typically, when I'm shooting
like this I might be solo lobo,
and there's no one
to hold a reflector.
So if I can find
a nice position,
a nice, soft window light
somewhere, hopefully
away from a lot of noise.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So let's go
back to the dramatic position,
though, maybe Zack
can hold the Flexfill
and put it in and
just you can see--
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
Or I can do that.
So here, come away from
the window a little bit
so it's even more dramatic.
Right?
Pretty dramatic.
So that's a pretty
dramatic, that's
a pretty intense lighting ratio.
But notice, using the Flexfill,
I can fill in the shadows.
Wax off.
Wax on.
If I use the matte white side,
the effect is more subtle.
Wax off.
Wax on.
So the Flexfill can provide you
with really nice fill light.
So typically, when
we're working outdoors
and we're going low tech,
Flexfill and Mother Nature.
Cinema is light moving in time.
CHRIS BOEBEL: [LAUGHS]
That's your wrap up?
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So I'll
just say that we've
looked at a lot of tools
today and everything
from clothespins, C-47s,
to Fresnel lights and more.
But ultimately, the most
important tool is your eye.
And that's what I was trying
to get at earlier when I talked
about actually seeing
what's in the scene
and making changes based
on what you're seeing.
Your eye is an
incredible instrument.
It's far better than any camera.
It's far more adaptable in
different lighting situations.
In fact, it's so good that
you have to sometimes learn
to see past it and see
what's actually there
and what a camera would see,
which is not as adaptable.
So it takes a lot of
practice until it eventually
becomes second nature.
But taking a look at the scene
and then making adjustments
either to your subject
or to the light,
whether they be lighting
instruments or windows,
is really the basic
process of doing lighting,
as it is the basic
process of almost
any aspect of filmmaking.
So thanks a lot, Dave.
I appreciate you coming in.
DAVID TAMES: Happy to come in.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Fantastic.
And--
DAVID TAMES: Lot of fun.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --your blog
Kino-Eye.com is a great
resource for not just lighting
tips, but video and media--
DAVID TAMES: Documentary mostly.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
--tips, documentary.
DAVID TAMES: And
I'd like to thank
Zack Ray for helping us today.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
thanks again also
to our terrific cameraman,
Jared [? Juniak, ?]
who is living what we're just
talking about as we film this.